alors facebook de développer une ia qui
comprend le monde à travers vos yeux
cette ia peut prédire le moment de votre
mort avec précision
li a prédit l'impact de l'apocalypse
climatique sur votre maison
en fait tous ces titres ils ont été
collectées à partir de recommandations
que j'ai eu quand c'était la semaine
dernière pour des articles sur internet
et il laisse plus ou moins tous pensé au
fait qu'il existe une ia qui serait
omnipotente qui pourrait gérer des idées
qui sont abstraites et puis qui pourrait
même parfois avoir une conscience voire
des sentiments
or force est de constater que sarah
connor n'a toujours pas rencontré le
terminator t800 et que probablement
aujourd'hui elle vit une retraite
tranquille quelque part aux états unis
et
quand on voit tous les adjectifs que
j'ai donnée par rapport à ses premiers
titres
finalement ils sont rattachés à ce qu'on
appelle l'intelligence artificielle
forte
et cette intelligence artificielle forte
elle est opposée à l'intelligence
artificielle qu'on dit faible dont je
vais vous parler aujourd'hui vous allez
voir que le mot faible est quand même
assez mal choisi
alors je suis docteur en neurologie et
je me suis particulièrement intéressé
dans ma thèse notamment à ou aux
algorithmes d'intelligence artificielle
et aux données médicales et donc c'est
avec un grand plaisir que je vais vous
parler de ça aujourd'hui et
je voudrais juste faire un petit 10 km
heure au début de cette présentation en
empruntant une phrase à paul valéry qui
dealent et qu'on devrait pour l'avoir en
tête quand on voit quelqu'un qui
vulgarise un sujet le faut le simple
parlons est toujours faux mais ce qui ne
l'est pas est inutilisable et donc je
vais essayer de vous dire le moins de
bêtises possibles pour essayer
résumé ce qu'est l'intelligence
artificielle qui a un sujet complexe
mais passionnant
alors je me suis posé la question de
savoir quelle définition je donnerais
pour qu'elle soit digest quand on me
demande ce que c'est qu'un algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle est en fait
pour moi c'est juste un formidable outil
à modéliser tout un tas de phénomène à
partir du moment où on a assez de
données les concernant
et les formules mathématiques en fait
qui sous-tendent les décisions de ses
algorithmes elles sont pas nouvelles
elles datent en réalité dit à plusieurs
dizaines d'années et elles sont devenues
applicable depuis peu à grande échelle
et pour ça il ya deux principales
raisons d'une part c'est l'explosion de
la puissance informatique et le fait que
cela devienne beaucoup plus accessible à
chacun d'entre nous puisque la preuve en
est on a tous assez de puissance
informatique à la maison pour faire
tourner un algorithme qui a aujourd'hui
est la deuxième raison c'est qu'il ya eu
des progrès phénoménal dans ce qu'ils
recueillent des données on a un nombre
de données beaucoup plus importants a
analysé avec ses algorithmes et
finalement aujourd'hui on dit qu'on est
haut dans le monde des big data donc
c'est des jeux de données qui ça a été
dit dans les présentations et voir que
j'en prends pas mal de trucs les
présentations précédentes finalement
cédé donné qu'ils ont
beaucoup de dimensions beaucoup de types
de données différents et qui sont
vraiment extrêmement massive et ça ça
bouleverse vous l'avez vu beaucoup de
domaines et notamment le domaine des
sciences comme la santé et il ya
quelqu'un qui a parlé de ça de manière
très claire c est chris anderson en 2008
il a fait il a écrit un essai et puis il
avait un titre provocateur
volontairement s'appelait the end of the
theory donc la fin des théories en
français et en fait ce qui nous explique
dans ce texte c'est que aujourd'hui
en fait on a changé de méthodologie en
sciences jusqu'ici on observait des
données puis on émettait une hypothèse
par rapport à ces données puis on les
teste lors d'une expérience or à l'ère
du big data et l'intelligence
artificielle en fait on a une capacité
d'observer des données qu'on
n'arriverait même pas une tellement les
dimensions sont grandes et puis l'autre
chose qui est assez incroyable c'est
qu'en fait on peut venir étudier ces
jeux de données parfois sans a priori
sans mais n'avoir d'hypothèses et pour
vous illustrer sa je prendrai un exemple
amusant que je tire du livre à quoi
rêvent les algorithmes nos vies à
l'heure du big data de dominique cardon
st-rémy bouquin pour ceux qui voudraient
creuser le sujet alors on va on va faire
un exemple qui est amusant hop
on va se mettre dans la peau d'un
assureur auto qui à partir de données
consommation dans un magasin donc dans
un supermarché de ses clients voudrait
déterminer s'il ya des patterns de
consommation le magasin qui serait
plutôt en lien avec une conduite
responsable sur la route ou bien qui
traduirait une conduite plus tôt
accidentogènes
et
avant l'intelligence artificielle on
peut y réfléchir on a une hypothèse qui
vient tout de suite en tête je pense à
tout le monde c'est de dire ce type de
consommation notamment l'alcool c'est
sans doute lié à une conduite qui est un
peu plus accidentogènes et donc
puisqu'on est à l'air avant le big data
avant l'intelligence artificielle mais
on va recueillir
précautionneusement chaque données sur
la consommation d'alcool de nos clients
puis on va définir un modèle et semaine
va le tester et on risque d'avoir de
très bons résultats
mais pour vous montrer le changement
aujourd'hui c'est que on va avoir non
pas certaines données qu'on va devoir
sélectionner mais là on va les avoir
toutes dans un espèce d'immense tableur
excel qu'il est très long de dérouler et
de regarder est on va juste demandé à
notre algorithme d'essayer de faire un
modèle prédictif à partir de ces données
de consommation et de voir s'il y en a
qui sont corrélés par exemple à une
conduite qui est responsable et quand on
fait ça on obtient ça alors je suis
breton mais j'ai pas osé ramener des
galettes dans ma présentation c'est pas
ça du tout c'est des feutres qu'on met
sous les meubles pour protéger le sol en
fait et ça peut paraître un résultat
complètement farfelue pour traduire une
conduite qui est plutôt responsable sur
la route mais en réalité quand on y
réfléchit c'est un peu ce qu'on cherche
c'est à dire à trouver des variables qui
ont un rôle central
dans le pronostic et qui pour autant
serait très dur à trouver dans nos
hypothèses préalable
alors tout ça c'est des supers résultats
mais comment on fait pour créer un
algorithme une intelligence artificielle
alors d'abord je lis créer mais en
général on crée pas grand chose en fait
on utilise des modèles qui existent déjà
qu'on va prendre et qu'on va utiliser
sur nos données en fait ils ont
différentes architectures
et vous connaissez sans doute tous vous
avez déjà tous entendu parler de des
réseaux de neurones et peut-être qu'il y
en a qui connaissent mieux le sujet qui
a entendu parler de forêt aléatoire ou
de deux supports vector machines des
choses comme ça donc on va choisir un de
ses algorithmes et on va pouvoir
justement lui donnez
lui faire subir on dit un apprentissage
superviser la plupart du temps c'est
beaucoup ce qu'on utilise c'est à dire
qu'on va l'entraîner avec des exemples
qui sont étiquetés auquel on lui donne
la réponse pour qu'ils apprennent sur
ces exemples et pour qu'après ils
définissent lui même nos données qui
sont les plus discriminantes pour
répondre à la question qu'on lui pose
est ici geo prendre un autre exemple et
on va se dire qu'on essaie de faire
ensemble un algorithme qui doit
reconnaître des voitures à lyon à partir
d'image donc on va devoir lui donner
énormément des images de voitures qui
passent à lyon et on va l'entraîner à
les reconnaître est ce qu'il ya de
formidable c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin de
lui définir à quoi ressemble une voiture
c'est que ici il va définir lui-même les
caractéristiques de l'image qui vont lui
évoqué une voiture en quelque sorte en
fait il crée sa propre définition
et après l'avoir entraîné on conserve
ses paramètres et on va les tester sur
d'autres images qu'il n'a jamais
rencontré
et là en l'occurrence puisque on est
tous très fort et on a réussi à faire un
alouette qui repère déjà quelques
véhicules dans l'image est
tout ça c'est très synthétique parce
qu'il ya d'autres méthodes
d'entraînement c'est laurent qui en a
parlé d'ailleurs tout à l'heure l'auto
apprentissage etc mais ça permet en fait
ces exemples déjà de devoir quelques
enjeux qui en lien avec ces technologies
quelques quelques-uns des plus grands
enjeux en fait qui existe et je viens de
quitter la présentation avec mon doigt
jaurès à tac
mais bien à partir du début je pense
qu'on est parti pour son
incroyable sec
sadc la télécommande qui m'a lâché cette
fois-ci up non c'est bon
donc voilà et donc en fait cet
algorithme à si on le vend demain en
thaïlande celui qu'on a entraîné à lyon
et qu'on lui dit et qu'on le vend à une
entreprise thaïlandaise et qu'il le
déploie en plein milieu de bangkok eh
ben on est très content mais je pense
que c'est le client qui va pas être
content du tout parce que quand il va
croiser ce type de véhicule mais
finalement
il va sans doute avoir des performances
qui vont être vraiment très largement en
dessous de nos attentes et je vais vous
dire que en fait les données qu'on
utilise finalement c'est peut-être
quatre plus capital dans ses algorithmes
et je vais vous parler d'un exemple que
je connais bien parce que ça a été mon
travail de thèse je vous préviens c'est
un petit peu morbide à partir de données
de patients qui venaient aux urgences
qui avait une hémorragie intracérébrale
j'essayais de déterminer quel était le
pronostic vital a un mois pour pouvoir
aiguilles et un petit peu les médecins
sur les prises en charge à adopter et
donc on a récupéré des données de
scanner des données cliniques les
antécédents des jambes et même des
données biologiques
et
en regardant tout ça il y avait des gens
qui l'avaient déjà fait par ailleurs
dans la littérature finalement on se
rend compte tout de suite que pour
certaines personnes il manque certaines
de ces informations et la simplicité
c'est
de se dire et c'est ce qui avait été
beaucoup fait jusqu'ici c'est à dire les
gens pour qu'ils montent des
informations on veut pas les analyser et
finalement quand j'ai regardé mes
données eh ben je me suis rendu compte
d'une chose c'est que le manque
d'information c'est aussi d'informations
et quand on compare la mortalité des
gens qui avait pas du tout de données
manquantes ont donc ici 11% donc il y
avait toutes les données recueillies à
l'entrée
avec celle des gens qui avaient des
données manquantes et mal à ça explose
ça triple en fait et finalement on était
en train d'entraîner un algorithme sur
la donne et des données de patients pour
définir des pronostics de futurs
patients à partir de données qui avait
en fait qui reflétait pas du tout la
réalité puisque sous-estimé très
largement la gravité de la pathologie et
quand on y réfléchit finalement masse
est assez logique parce que des gens qui
arrivent en commun aux urgences pour
savoir s'ils fument ou s'ils avaient de
l'hypertension des fois c'est hyper
difficile
et donc
une autre chose qu'on peut comprendre
via ces exemples c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'expliqué habilités des choix de
l'algorithme et ça ça c'est hyper
important de le comprendre voire contre
notre exemple de notre algorithme qui
définissait des voitures qui marchait
pas en thaïlande mais qui marchait bien
sûr ce type de véhicule
quand on demande à un humain pourquoi
c'est une voiture c'est facile il ya
derrière de phare et un pare-brise
rétroviseur quand on demande à un
algorithme à c'est lui qui choisit les
caractéristiques de l'image est en fait
quand il les choisit lui va voir des
densité de pixels il va avoir des
distances il va voir tout un tas de
données qu'en fait
ils sont très très compliqué à
comprendre pour nous et qui veulent un
petit peu rien dire et ça c'est très
embêtant notamment dans le domaine de la
santé parce que on va se retrouver avec
un choix algorithmique qui veut le dire
ce patient peut-être décédé dans 30 juin
et pour autant on n'a pas de visibilité
sur
le pourquoi de cet algorithme a fait ce
choix et ça ça va avoir c'est un domaine
dans lequel il ya énormément de
recherches actuellement dans le domaine
de l'intelligence artificielle est
d'autant plus qu'on s'est rendu compte
que finalement
les choix de l'algorithme on avait en
plus énormément de mal à les remettre en
question c'est un monsieur qui a
théorisé un petit peu tout ce qui aide à
la décision en santé qui s'appelle
enrico choléra qui a montré une chose
qui est hyper l'impressionnante c'est
que quand un médecin est aidé dans ses
prescriptions par un algorithme si
l'algorithme dit vrai sur la nécessité
de prescrire tel ou tel médicament alors
on réduit le risque d'erreur de 59%
or quand l'algorithme dit faux et ben en
fait on augmente le risque d'erreur de
86% et donc ça nous montre bien que non
seulement il faut s'attacher à voir des
algorithmes qui soit très précis qui
disent dès qu'ils disent pas de bêtises
mais qu'en plus ils soient informatifs
sur la décision qu'ils ont donnée donc
finalement
on a parlé des biais possibles en
introduit par les données on a parlé de
l'expliquent habilités des résultats et
il y aura encore bien bien d'autres
sujets est en jeu a discuté avec vous
aujourd'hui puis vous voyez que après
cinq représentations finalement c'est
impossible de tout résumé mais j'espère
que moi je vous aurez apporté une chose
c'est que la prochaine fois que vous
verrez un titre aguicheur concernant
l'intelligence artificielle bah vous
aurez envie d'approfondir vos recherches
parfois pour trouver des choses
dérangeantes parfois plutôt des sujets
enthousiasmant mais en tout cas toujours
des choses très intéressantes parce que
derrière mes titres ici se cachait le
projet ego cadets qui était un projet d'
analyse d'image à la première personne
avec un côté très black mirror
derrière ce deuxième titre se cachait le
médical brain de google qui cherche avec
des données non structurées à définir le
pronostic de patience un domaine
vraiment passionnant d'études et puis
enfin derrière ce dernier titre on
parlait du travail à de mercato richard
institute qui est un institut qui a
analysé les conséquences climatiques à
différents points géographiques à partir
des données de la littérature sur le
sujet voilà je vous remercie beaucoup
pour notre attention
[Applaudissements]